Er ist jung, er hat studiert,
aber er verkauft sich für billiges Geld.
Eine Kampagne gegen Lohndumping:
Die Idee stammt von diesen
beiden Geschäftspartnern.
Das war ja der Slogan
gegen Kreativ-Prostitution.
Also wir wollen einfach verhindern, dass
die Leute sich unter Wert verkaufen.
Arbeiten zu Niedriglöhnen
in der Kreativbranche
– damit haben sie auch
schon Erfahrung gemacht.
Deshalb gründeten sie
ihre Vermittlungsagentur für Kreative.
Es gibt auf der einen Seite die Entwicklung,
dass Leute immer mehr ausgebeutet werden.
Es gibt Plattformen wo man dann …
wo 100 Leute irgendwie ein Logo designen
und nur der Gewinner
erhält dann Geld dafür.
Das sehen wir einfach
als absolute Ausbeutung.
Die Berliner Kreativbranche trifft
sich in solchen hippen „Workspaces“:
Webdesigner, Texter, Fotografen.
Doch manche von ihnen
müssen mit Honoraren
auf Sozialhilfe-Niveau auskommen
– knapp 1000 Euro im Monat.
In ihrem Firmenvideo
zeigen die Jobvermittler,
wie sie Arbeitgeber und
Arbeitnehmer zusammenbringen.
Sie vermitteln die Kreativen
zu einem festen Tagessatz.
Viele sagen ja immer:
300 Euro als Tagessatz, das klingt zu viel.
Das ist ganz normal für Leute, die mit
Freelancern nichts zu tun haben, ja.
Aber wenn man das mal hoch und runter
rechnet kommt man halt schnell darauf,
dass man da keine Rente von zahlen kann,
dass man da nichts davon zurücklegen kann.
Esther Schaarhüls ist Grafikdesignerin.
Sie wurde von den beiden an
eine Werbeagentur vermittelt.
Dafür erhalten sie zehn Prozent
Provision von ihrem Honorar.
Dann ging es
eigentlich relativ schnell,
also ich glaub innerhalb von zwei
Tagen hat die erste Agentur angerufen
und dann eine Woche später die nächste
und mittlerweile gibt es auch Agenturen,
die dann auch wiederkommen.
Berlin: ein Eldorado für die
internationale Kreativszene.
Doch für jeden Dritten
reicht das Geld kaum zum Leben.
Statt alleine zu Hause zu sitzen,
arbeitet Esther Schaarhüls lieber
zusammen mit anderen Selbstständigen.
Hier findet sie Anregungen,
Kontakte und manchmal auch neue Jobs.
Ihr Tagessatz erscheint hoch –
auf den ersten Blick.
Also theoretisch fängt [es] bei 450 an,
450, 500 Euro, und, wie oft?
Also das kommt sehr drauf an.
Im Sommer ist es ganz oft so,
dass man öfter mal gebucht wird,
aber dann heißt es
jetzt auch nicht jeden Tag,
sondern das ist dann vielleicht ein,
zwei Mal im Monat,
dann ist aber auch wieder
zwei Monate nichts.
Weltweit wächst der Markt
für die kreative Bohème.
Sie sind jung,
wollen unabhängig sein.
Doch über die Schattenseiten
sprechen sie ungern:
Nach jedem Auftrag
wartet die Ungewissheit.
Sie sind gewerkschaftlich nicht
organisiert, es fehlen Tarifabschlüsse.
Ihre „schöne heile Welt“
belächeln manche mit Zynismus.
Tagessatz?
Hast du gerade Tagessatz gesagt?
Wow, ehrlich gesagt,
in der Kategorie denk ich gar nicht.
Du kriegst genug Geld,
damit du nicht verhungerst,
und das ist es dann auch.
Und dann arbeitest du irgendwie
zwischen 8 und 16 Stunden
und manchmal auch 20.
Manchmal auch 24,
das ist aber selten –
aber in Tagessätzen
kannst du nicht rechnen.
Aber die Grafikdesignerin
hat für sich dazugelernt –
auf Lohndumping lässt sie sich
heute nicht mehr ein.
Da muss man dann, auch um seine eigene
Energie und auch um seinen eigenen …
dass man auch seine Unkosten hat
und [um] das zu schützen,
muss man einfach auch hingehen und …
und Grenzen setzen.
In ganz Deutschland arbeiten 1,5
Millionen Menschen in der Kreativbranche.
Aber anders als Esther Schaarhüls
schaffen es die meisten nicht,
den Wert ihrer Arbeit
auch durchzusetzen.